hide your kids that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now it's often said that the children
are our future
and of course that's exactly why the
left wants to take them from parents who
don't buy into their twisted agenda
everywhere you look in myriad ways
forces are working overtime
to undermine parental rights and their
judeo-christian values
from teachers unions to gender activists
to biden's vaccine pushers
we're seeing a concerted effort backed
by some of the
biggest financial interests out there to
indoctrinate our children
into a dark mindset of anti-americanism
now this new normal requires the
undermining of american history
it involves teaching concepts directly
at odds with the ideal of the nuclear
family
now on the covet issue government and
so-called public health experts
are trying to force your kids to get
injected with an experimental covert
vaccine whether you want them to or not
as the angle revealed last night the
biden administration
is about to take their pressure campaign
to your doorstep
we are going to continue to press to get
12 to 18 year olds vaccinated to
continue to
uh work with communities where there's
lower vaccination rates that's one of
the reasons we
initiated these um these for these
strike forces to go into communities and
work with them to determine what they
need
strike forces president xi must be very
proud that language now but today hhs
secretary basara
took it to an even more sinister level
biden's vaccine militia
will apparently be asking household
adults questions
about the family's vaccine status and
god knows what else
perhaps we should point out that the
federal government has had it spent
trillions of dollars to try to keep
americans alive during this pandemic so
it is
absolutely the govern government's
business it is taxpayers business
if we have to continue to spend money to
try to keep people from contracting
covet
and helping reopen the economy knocking
on a door has never been against the law
first javier it's not your department's
role to pry into the medical decisions
of american citizens
second the economy has already reopened
and has been for
a year in red states third we trust
parents
not the bureaucrats who've misled us
consistently to make important family
health decisions
now republican officials are already
pushing back and this is great
missouri's governor mike parson
politely told the feds to take their
vaccine evangelization elsewhere
and the arizona ag in a letter to
president biden raised the issue of
medical privacy
writing i will not tolerate such
intrusions within arizona if americans
are on the fence about taking the covet
19 vaccine
it would be most inappropriate for
bureaucrats to single them out
regardless of motivations or intentions
now the white house is claiming that
it's not going to keep vaccination data
a database and that all door knockers
are just going to be volunteers so don't
worry about it
but given their raw obsession with
vaccinating kids
who rarely get ill from kovid no wonder
few trust them
now things are so bad in my old home
state of connecticut
that parents there are suing to enjoin a
new law that requires kindergarteners
to be vaccinated even if it violates
parents religious beliefs
but when it comes to directly violating
parental parental rights dc takes the
cake
now in a story we brought you last night
new legislation there
allows children as young as 11 years old
to get any vaccine including covet 19s
without
parental consent the attorney
representing the father who's suing d.c
in federal court over this
appeared on the ingram angle last night
the law actually
requires the doctor the school
the health insurance company and the
health department
to all actively conceal from the parent
that the child has received the vaccine
this law is not only
encouraging lying it actually mandates
by law
an elaborate scheme of lying to their
own parent
unbelievable now it's not just
connecticut and dc subverting parental
rights
alabama allows 14 year olds to get the
vaccine without parental consent
oregon allows 15 year olds to get it and
in rhode island and south carolina you
can get it at 16.
now this is just unacceptable none of
these states
allow tattoos for those under the age of
18 without parental permission
but they're allowing minors to get an
experimental drug
a brand new study out of england
revealing tonight that
children are even more resilient to
covid than we actually thought
some 99.995
of the 469 982 children in england
who were infected during the year
examined by researchers
survived but that doesn't matter to the
left
and it's not going to stop their
anti-parental trends
which are perhaps most pernicious in our
schools
now if kids aren't being bombarded by
non-stop
hectoring on race and white privilege
they're being forced to read sexually
explicit books with little to no
literary value
chicago takes things a step further from
reading assignments focused on sex
to actually encouraging students to have
sex
free condoms for fifth graders isn't
that nifty
forget that this also means encouraging
fifth graders to violate illinois law
that prohibits sex with minors no big
deal
there but parents i gotta say don't
worry
because the experts say that condoms in
elementary schools
will stop the bad stuff from happening
now left-wing egocrats who relish
pushing the sexual envelope and
redefining gender
have zero respect for parental
boundaries
conversations that are best left between
parents and their children
are being short-circuited in states like
california and new york
and by the way remember one of new
york's fanciest schools
is teaching first graders about
masturbation
and when adults cry foul as we have
against
things like critical race theory being
taught in our schools
the elites and their activist base they
move into smear mode
and of course they don't hesitate to lie
cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history
accurate history randy topping the list
of suggested reading for teachers and
high school students
is of course the book how to be an
anti-racist by ebram kennedy
it's filled with historical inaccuracies
and totalitarian policy ideas
remember ibram writes that capitalism is
essentially racist
and racism is essentially capitalist oh
how clever i guess that means everyone
who works then
is racist kids that means your parents
then are part of the problem and they
meet immediately those parents of yours
need to begin their never-ending
re-education
in anti-racism and if you even raise the
slightest doubt about white privilege
or this concept of systemic racism
democrat state media
they will defame you followers of q and
on
who are now using the battle cry to
similarly target
school boards with many who have
espoused q anon
theories now melding their own
conspiracies
with the lies about critical race theory
that's so weak
parents of all races and ethnicities who
are raising concerns about their kids
education
which by the way they pay for that's
like cueing on
joy well totalitarian societies depend
on propagandizing
and their leaders ruthlessly enforce its
dissemination
give me four years to teach the children
and the seed i have sown
will never be uprooted that was from
vladimir lenin
we can't afford to give our would-be
cultural totalitarians
four more weeks with our kids let alone
four more years
and that's the angle